when i think about the wilderness of
denali
i think of vastness and how small we are
in that great big
wintery world
sled dogs are not the national park
services idea this is an idea that we
have adopted from everyone else who knew
that dog teams were just the best most
reliable
and i'd argue most fun way to travel
around alaska in winter
[Music]
so i'm the kennels manager in denali
national park and preserve
and i'm in charge of the only sled dog
kennel in the entire national park
service
[Music]
in 1980 the original park boundary was
designated as wilderness
and officially designated wilderness is
the highest level of federal land
protection available and it means that
you can't use any motorized form of
transport to travel
it's all going to be through
non-motorized transport so dog teams
skis snow shoes anything like that
this is your teeth these dogs are all
alaskan huskies
born and raised for thousands of years
to live in the harsh winter conditions
of alaska and to want to run and pull a
sled ready
[Music]
asking me my favorite dog is like asking
a parent their favorite child
it's not possible to answer that
question they all win my heart in some
way or another
these guys are amazing they bridge the
gap to the wild
i think the dogs are just an incredible
invitation and inspiration for our
visitors
we're all a part of this wilderness
we're all a part of this place and it
has so much to offer us if we're willing
to go out and
be challenged by it a little to immerse
ourselves in it
[Music]
you